to top Cardinals had an audience with
Pope Francis at the Vatican this morning
they are discussing the widening sex
abuse scandal the Pope yesterday called
for top bishops from around the world to
attend the summit at the Vatican in
February this comes as a new scandal is
developing in Germany more than 1600
clerics and priests are accused of
sexually abusing more than 3,600 minors
over about 70 years Seth Doane is
following the Pope's response from the
Vatican south good morning good morning
the Vatican says that the Pope has
reflected deeply on this crisis of sex
abuse which is rocking the church and
which was the topic of those
conversations today with those u.s.
Cardinals including Sean O'Malley the
Cardinal of Boston who is the top papal
advisor on sex abuse and also Cardinal
Daniel DiNardo of Galveston Texas who is
the head of US bishops it was DiNardo
who back in August had called for this
audience with the Pope and is really
pushing for a full Vatican investigation
into the issue of the former dis no
disgraced Cardinal Theodore McCarrick
who resigned from his post in the summer
after accusations were deemed credible
that he had abused a minor nearly 50
years ago a wave of other allegations
that he'd also abused seminarians
emerged around that same time and it was
seen that that was an open secret at the
Vatican
now DiNardo is asking for outsiders to
play a role in church investigations and
for new channels to be established to
report abuse and this is all taking
place now as new allegations are
emerging this morning in a new twist
that Cardinal DiNardo is being accused
of covering up a predator priest who was
operating in his area Yale this only
further complicates matters as he's
pushing the Vatican for action a lot of
layers to that story Seth Doane thank
you reporting from Rome